foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
I see that smack talking that you guys
doing in the chat don't think I don't
see that
I see it
[Music]
I see you guys
okay I gotta I gotta works
[Music]
me
let me fix the screen
we'll be watching it at just YouTube
right
so we're gonna do it on Twitch I mean we
can it doesn't matter to me
I'll be thinking twitch be a little bit
faster bro
but if we're on the same part does it
matter
this is true
me
hold up hold up babe
what you know
four minutes
should I follow them
no I'm not gonna have to sign in and do
that [__]
[Music]
foreign
ERS to do with this
I couldn't find no one at the last
minute
let's see Fun's really on
[Music]
who's in the chat
who's in the chat man
I call it a couple people
let me hide the website
hey babe I'm I'm live
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
question do you guys like the the
reactions like this because I usually
just stretch it just a little bit on the
top and bottom
y
okay what are you doing here
[Music]
stop
I gotta have like three screens open
[Music]
foreign
I don't understand what you mean by the
layouts of r r look nicer you have to be
a little bit more specific on that uh JT
they like the whatchamacallit
no it seems like he doesn't like
the r r layout
he said he doesn't like it I don't know
that's why I'm asking him where's he
wrote is he Super Chat there
no
oh
one time you know there's criticism
that's not super chats right
okay
yeah listen I'm asking you a question
because I wanted to see something
that's all I wasn't you know trying to
come at it though
since you implying
let me go ahead and
[Music]
stream
what
say it's about to get funky
six seconds to end see you got it at six
seconds you said 54 over there
started
and welcome to the state of play
today we can hear your uh your stuff
you're muted
all right
that don't make no sense
I hope you'll stay with us until the end
of the show and enjoy everything
okay never mind no we're hearing
no you're fine I'm hearing um
The Interpreter and the person speaking
so it sounds like I'm hearing double why
she was dominant
and only in the dominant
Focus so the whole joint is about Final
Fantasy uh I don't know success
yes sergeant
okay
why it look like Monster Hunter I said
Focus wyvern
it looks nice though
yeah you're into that
home sweet home
allow me to just look like Monster
Hunter I'm not a huge fan of the color
scheme of Monster Hunter Final Fantasy
16 is the latest installment in the
Final Fantasy series a storied franchise
with 35 years of History
water this is the 16th Mainline title in
the series there's absolutely no need to
have played any of the previous games
before jumping in with a fusion of
real-time action and RPG features Final
Fantasy 16 has been developed as the
first true action RPG in the series
using the power of the PlayStation 5 to
its fullest the game delivers an
expansive thrilling gameplay experience
I'm really worried about this game
because it feels like it's another 13
moment where they're spending too much
time focusing on the Aeons or whatever
they're calling them it could work out
well for them and maybe they do what
they promise in 13 but with a little
summons yeah there's some
a little dope
I mean I just don't like the drive color
scheme though that's all that's all
other than that
you look good
pretty much King in this world there's
like Jin Cherokee from Naruto where they
have the summons in them
oh that's what's up yeah
that's actually probably okay you can
explain it all right so he got like a
nine tails in them yeah he's got it and
his journey yeah okay it takes place in
the realm of valestine
I do like how they're making it a a
country on Country War thing
I feel like Final Fantasy is at its best
when there's when there's more going off
see now I like the colors like you see
how the colors look more vibrant
[Music]
like the other stuff look like early
footage this look like all right this is
what I'm talking about I'm right let's
get it baby
all right back to the pivotal events
that shaped his past hobbins presence
but
um
and thus does the curtain open on this
newest final fantastic bloody face what
have you done release the beast kind sir
give me like really Dragon Age Vibes
that give me a real Game of Thrones and
if they're smart they're they're playing
like Game of Thrones like you know the
Lannisters and uh House of
um of these dudes so you instead of into
focus on like individual characters
focus on like family the house yeah
I don't think that's what they're gonna
do but each house has their own
individual characters you know that's
Phoenix
it looks nice
all right flame Rising oh trees look
good
effort looks mad weird
different yeah
we don't know if it evolves
and the map looks cool
[Music]
I like the Overworld the colorfulness
with locations being added and updated
as players progress through the main
narrative
she makes me feel for a modern day
Castlevania encounter formidable folks
and uncover great and wondrous Mysteries
hey to Corpus
well this is the exploration they wanted
for 15 but really didn't
executed as well as they could have yeah
looks like
um I swim in Dragon Hunter I just hope
the story is lit
like
they don't really you know shy away from
um the last couple games was
disappointing to me
up to you yeah
I don't know
like this is my bread and butter like
this is my origins of gaming in Final
Fantasy
yeah so we were holding in super high
regard
um I I couldn't even say that this is my
Origins into RPGs
yeah the combat looks good it looks like
they evolved it
I like the tracking the story the
multi-hit combos yeah but you know he's
at our elevated level of course
I like it you know now let's take a
moment to admire Clyde I've never really
had a problem with final fantasy's
combat
any way that they wanted to go if they
wanted to go turn base
mad Devil May Cry
well I like the combos to it but it
feels like Monster Hunter mixed with a
little bit of Devil May Cry
so it does look like you can change your
summer
it looks like there's some time
okay
[Music]
I don't know
I feel like it's Dynasty Warriors just
fighting random at like a bunch of ass
oh look at that
[Music]
you can link it to that ah this is gonna
be a very unique way to play
depending on how you choose to play
the abilities that Clive wields have
unique characters it's going to lean
into a lot of playthroughs
players can use ability points collected
by defeating energies
upgrade existing ones
can't decide which iconic abilities to
unlock or upgrade no problem quite
possible you can let the game choose for
you
[Music]
Final Fantasy 16 includes a range of
timely accessories to provide support
Engineers bringing them a truly
enjoyable experience counter counter
with different combinations
[Music]
the one that perfectly matches their own
play style
switch up
a combination
gameplay is the ring of timely focus and
the Ring of timely strikes
this combination allows players to but
this can only be done for this super
fast SSD
as well as shifting into a window a slow
motion
so they've got a stagger bar back in
from 13.
looks nice alternatively players could
equip an accessory all right so screen
brightness as I said before I really
encourage everyone to discover the
combination that works best for them
so they give you an accessory you know
Screw of 80. we got we got something to
use
oh screw getting good King we got
something for you if you want to
concentrate on the story don't forget to
choose story Focus mode before starting
a new game thanks PlayStation
in this mode timely accessories are
automatically equipped from the start
allowing players to immerse themselves
in the narrative experience without
having to worry too much with the action
you know what I like about this
generation
even the generic NPCs I bet you I bet
you they're going to show a performance
vote on here
they
I doubt it
no there was a performance Journey who
will join him as friends and allies if
you look if you read the uh menus you
saw it uh for 1440p you know 60 frames
I said office so it becomes a mentor to
Clive
all right
Jill a friend from Clive's youth it
really is such encounters and reunions
will set Clive on a path of Rich
personal growth
[Music]
along the way
that said players to get the one wall is
on his back
oh Cliff just made a very interesting
tweet
just got a text from our lawyer about
law Breakers stay tuned
yeah see you in Game Pass Cliff you're
welcome
[Music]
thank you
we'll talk later
oh
and we cannot forget torbel
[Music]
well I'm so far ahead is crazy fiercely
loyal Hound
applied side and willing to stand by him
in the face of whatever cruel fate May
befall them
yeah that's crazy but players can also
give him directions come on carrying
girls when you're back
mm-hmm
stairs
well none will don't fret about Karen
I've taken care of her fee all of it
you have nothing to worry about they
made that seem like it's going a
completely different way I took care of
her feet gear upstairs
the game
access to Sid's Hideaway
did I said Sid's been in every Final
Fantasy but two
here in the Hideaway
Japanese too when you can purchase
armor and consumable such as potions
training mode block Thorn a highly
skilled blacksmith works the hideaway's
forge
to craft New Gear or upgrades
after upgrading your equipment or
unlocking new abilities try accessing
the oretus stone seems like they're
giving you a ton
[Music]
here players can enter a virtual
training area I'll see how this can be
done on Xbox space
yeah somebody got paid I want to know
the floor during checks let's go you're
confident in your skills FTC look at me
let's get me on the FTC
the last people bye Hideaway is home
gotta look into these contracts see fake
friends ready
welcoming committee
dying on the vine
not only I don't know some areas have a
lot to be desired and some areas look
really good also view information I
should look like she's straight out of
Destiny
this is giving me mad Final Fantasy 12
Vibes I like the way they're doing these
you like it
I'll have to play it
see I'm still
in the start to accept live live combat
away from turn base but like seven
remakes showed me they can do it where
it feels nice you know what I'm saying
get back yeah so I have to see how they
do this
I like turn boots
call me a purist call me uh flip they
got that they got the boards from uh
from Monster Hunters that's what I'm
telling you it looks like yeah those
boards have been in Final Fantasy for a
while I'm just I'm just messing
yeah but it does look like Monster
Hunter
fearsome foes
the thousands tombs
oh wow I would love for them to do it
looking like this
hypocrite is oh I I killed a few of them
in 10. Final Fantasy 10.
and there's also luresman Hippocrates
these secrets
Tales of his adventures
oh man too bad you don't got watching
quality primer books out
sitting there quite the five things
I just I guess to me king I see people
like
like um
Dragon Quest
implementing and Vivian live action and
turn base and I just find it hard to
believe Cheryl be more work but I feel
like you'll sell more you know what I'm
saying it was crazy when I was playing
Dragon Quest I was playing in um
slop monster
[Music]
this is the bio is that all the uh
Titans live in
[Music]
on his travels Clive will encounter a
wide array of fearsome foes
oh yes
oh Dragoon kind of look like the uh Kane
from Final Fantasy IV oh
QuickTime event
you're a little ahead of us I know
oh
see this combat looks good
it's just how often you realistically
going to perform this kind of stuff you
know what I'm saying it depends on what
matches you're in
it looked pretty good right there
oh snap
you go
smash
[Music]
light em up light them up just this this
is this is the first thing I've seen
that actually getting you a little hype
of course clash with the dominance who
wield the power of the icon
okay
[Music]
it says look like he's using Titan to
put his uh armored skin on top of his uh
human skin
colossal beasts
under their sway
constructs of the following a
civilization shrouded in mystery it
looked like they went with a new like
Art Studio it feels like they put a lot
of Kingdom Hearts expert uh like
inspired Combat on this but they they
made a scene oh bombs look crazy yeah no
those aren't bombs so those are some
bombs we talk about those dancing they
look bombs at first because they were
circles
[Music]
Barber
oh
it looks like he's got Bahama in it I
don't know look at the top left it looks
like he's switching between the icons
yeah I'm looking at it
experience unparalleled real-time action
combat as Clive takes command of the
iconic might I like the characters from
this more than I like the characters
from uh
15 though when it was right there in the
car yeah that was like standing point of
Final Fantasy it has to be the
breathtaking icon versus yeah these are
what I'm interested in
smack the hell out of them
down here
get down here I mean I'm gonna review it
I love Final Fantasy like even even
though I wasn't the only one I
absolutely hated was 13. I couldn't
stand 13. Bill the wrath of Odin that's
the fragrance
oh Odin Odin is it Odin's in the game
yeah
oh oh depending on the icon encountered
that's Ramsey rammus right down to
gameplay players will experience
everything from a 3D scrolling shooter
wrestling match
oh Bahamas the entire Battlefield
I like the fact that you get a chance to
fight with God
I want to know it makes sense while
you're fighting you know what I'm saying
like I hope so I hope it's just not like
you place it for it for a chapter in his
in the final boss for his chapter is
tight you know what I'm saying no all
right so you're gonna see something
before you know uh King you could huge
what aeon goes into the fight
okay so you just saw it right you're
seeing it right now and but if you can
do it your boy
yeah he's fighting the Titan right now
okay
alerted
[Music]
peanuts yeah
and he learns that move
[Music]
this looks good this looks good yeah
thank God they're giving me something to
turn on my PlayStation
I'm gonna turn my PlayStation on because
they're about to lose 35 games so I
gotta play them
oh
that sucks we got stuff coming out and
they gonna get rid of
oh whatever
oh yeah so you know what I guess
everybody's always asked for this always
acts to control the summons for more
than a couple of seconds and in this
game that has you know it seemed to be a
reality
we are able to control something the
only thing the only
concern is I just want these fights to
make sense that's all I believe
I have enough confidence that they
waited this long to allow you to control
the Summers more than just the these set
pieces are intense though
they remind me of reminiscent of early
God of War real God of War
not that thing that we got look at if
we're just Free Falling
wait till you see what he does
I'm about this
I'm about
this comes out in June
like I said I'm about
thank you for checking it out
good luck have a blessed day
it's been nice bro
go knock it out the park here
what's up everyone what did you think
thank you for taking the time to join us
today Final Fantasy 16. I think they
showed us a little too much of the Aeons
fighting though 20 seconds like and
they're still they I think they named
Minnesota's every aeon fight
real game
in the near future also I'm truly
excited to finally be able to reveal
okay 16's main theme was written and
performed Japan's greatest recording
artists
we've still got a lot more in store for
you in the coming weeks and I hope you
all pre-order the game and join us in
balastia on release day this has been
known I hope they they get back to you
that's it bro
all right
I personally felt like they could have
shoved more than just this one game
I think they did a good job
I think they did a good job I'm not even
gonna sit in cap I think they did a good
job
um for a game that I would really
probably wasn't interested in to to make
me interested in it
um yeah they did a good job
it looked good
[Music]
um
I like the fact that you you can use the
summons more than you know uh the cut
scene it's that's yo we got 283 people
in here let's get those likes up
me and addict did this on the spur of
the moment and guess what we didn't
coordinate shirts We Just Vibe like that
yeah that's how we run crazy right
coordinate people think we have time for
all that I know right and we did get
some super chats that I should probably
get to okay yeah let's get to those
Super Chat all right so we got a two
dollar Super Chat from Hollywood uh
Hollywood rolls just saying what's up my
boy's been some week yeah it definitely
was uh two dollar Super Chat from Randy
G is it me or the frame rate look like
30. it kind of looked like 60 to me no
it was 30. it was a hard 30. uh the the
fights look 60. I don't know no hard 30.
I have to physically play the game
before I could tell what it is uh
Nintendo the dawn uh Zelda two dollars
Zelda clears easy
then two dollar super trap from free R
Kelly can't wait to play this on Xbox oh
wait
you could play it right next to
Starfield
Bang
[Music]
this game's lunch for breakfast though I
think Zelda eats this game's lunch for
breakfast I don't care about that it's
about everybody's having an exclusive
RPGs this is the year the RPG fellas
don't fraud yourself out of this don't
fraud yourself out of it so you Nintendo
dudes don't fraud yourself out of it if
you got a PlayStation go cop your Xbox
dude you got a PlayStation go cop you
got star feel for Xbox latest so what
see you later you got Zelda for Nintendo
so what see you later
you gotta get this for your PlayStation
don't don't front if you're a RPG dude
come on man get out there stop playing
around stop capping now if your pocket's
looking kind of stink
yeah you might have to do some things to
go get that you might have to do some
things but some things it ain't nothing
wrong if you got to do a little strange
for some change just go do what you got
to do don't talk about it don't let you
nobody know what you did just go get
that we won't ask about it don't worry
just just post your gameplay and I know
you did some things to get some stuff
yeah do a king that's popping that game
pass game take a picture of the title
screen and close out of it
just don't play no more
Zelda looks like DLC no I don't think
that looks like DLC y'all gotta stop
with the cat man so what if you don't
want to buy the DLC I'm buying the hell
out that DLC
I don't think none of them look like DLC
you even got a war you stretching the
hell out of me stop that
what were you saying
pause that's what I said cut that out
man cut that out
yo
everybody
I don't care if you if you are Xbox dude
don't cap bro it look good if you're a
Nintendo dude yo cat bro it look good if
your PlayStation dude put your guns in
it
it's on in June that's your E3 right
there it's on in June they talking about
Starfield you say so what I don't care
they talking about Zelda you say so what
I don't care
stop playing why are you acting up he
acting up so bad all right guys we out
of here
right now he's he's addict is is so
ridiculous he's he's just too much he's
just pause man come on man come on man
look and then he's doing stretchy face
yo I'll catch you guys later yo
but outros all right go ahead
yo state of play was dope
um uh if if you want me to rate this
Final Fantasy and I'm just glad they
just came out to give people a little
bit more of the game to let people know
that it's not just
um cutscenes for um the summons
I always ask for that so we finally got
a game
where you get a chance to play as Ifrit
or play as bio mutt or or get a chance
to play as Shiva or or whoever you know
so I don't know man um when I call down
Odin or Knights of the Round and do what
I gotta do not stop around uh
you said excuse you Odin is not part of
Knights of the Round I said if I call in
Odin or Knights of the Round I thought
you said all right excuse you excuse
me
and we're out of here because attic is
tired he's probably a little hungry
right now you know we know we went five
hours so
yeah and we'll see you uh we'll see you
Sunday guys we have a oh really
this weekend
um let me tell them the movies that I'm
gonna go see oh I'm gonna go see Mario
again but the Pope's Exorcist is uh came
out
um I'm gonna go see that I'm gonna go
see Renfield Renfield releases tomorrow
and the Pope's Exorcist yeah and what's
the next one oh air the joint with
Michael Jordan I'm gonna go check that
out all right so I'm gonna go see air
I'm gonna go see the Pope's Exorcist and
I'm gonna go see Renfield and I'm gonna
go see Mario again so uh yeah yo if
y'all don't know about this Regal app
go get the Regal app and go take your
behind in the movies oh it's it's game
pass for movie theaters a shout out to
stitch 669 uh with the two dollar Super
Chat Sony don't have a first party RPG
they rent them though this is true so
what don't cap it's over there that's
the only place you could play it I can't
get it on PC for unless for six months
all right so we will be having a
community day Saturday as of my
knowledge right now that could change
but right now we're having one Saturday
um you know another thing I want to
mention is you know definitely be
looking out Sunday we're going to be
having like a really big event for you
guys you know really go above and beyond
we have the the entire
episode I don't know how long it's gonna
be I'm I'm trying to keep it realistic
uh but I think you guys will enjoy this
week but 300 300. but we're gonna go
ahead and sign out of here